il faut il faut que tu sois attentif il
faut pas lâcher l'appareil parce que
nous voyons à n'importe quel
comportement il faut le prendre
tu vois je veux dire ll faut pas
tergiverser quoi pour brut j'ai pu
suivre fabrice martinez un passionné de
gorille qui a créé dans les années 80
une association pour venir en aide aux
rangers qui protègent cette espèce
menacée on est partis au coeur du parc
national de kahuzi biega à l'est de la
république démocratique du congo pour
vous montrer comment une famille de gori
vie dans son habitat naturel
ça va tu vois bien qui c'est qui nous
accompagnent bon c'est qu'il ya appris
les pili pili pili
dans l'oréal général cinq personnes qui
parlent sinon j'allais jouer bonne
visite
merci beaucoup merci à tout à l'heure
les gens savent à mandela on est parti
allez on y va tu as déjà vu les gorilles
traversé la piste là
cette belle image ça
ce que j'aime dans l'idée de protéger
les gorilles c'est aussi de venir en
aide aux gens parce que les gens
finalement la nature la nature les gens
les gorilles tout est dit on ne peut pas
protéger les gorilles
si en même temps on vient pas aider les
gens qui habitent aux limites des parcs
j'ai tout fait pour pour leur apporter
une aide concrète qui s'est traduite
notamment par les équipements pour les
patrouilles anti braconnage mais bien
d'autres choses
si chaque famille de goulia son secteur
bien approprié et nous avons une
sous-espèce de gorille qui est vraiment
rare endémique au monde
c'est le gorille des plaines orientales
tout autour de moi j'ai toute une équipe
de soixante pisteurs il inclut aussi les
guides et c'est que nous faisons juste
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre nous
déploie 6-10 jour au lendemain mais
chaque famille débris a dit et 5
pisteurs
belga
les rangers qui sont un travail
formidable ils prennent des risques tous
les jours tous les jours pour sauver ce
territoire ces territoires protégés ils
dorment au plus près des animaux et
malgré tout malgré tout la difficulté et
la permanente le danger la permanence
chaque année des écogardes eux sont tués
tués par des groupes armés
il gagne très peu leur vie contrairement
aux efforts qu'il déploie je veux les
aider je veux continuer à les aider
[Musique]
donc on vient d'abandonner la piste
principale et puis là on vient de
rentrer dans la forêt on connaît dans
l'habitat naturel des gorilles de grauer
donc à partir de là on va aller
doucement on va éviter de faire du bruit
pour ne pas déranger la faune sauvage
les pisteurs sont essentiellement des
pics mais ceux qui ont la connaissance
de la forêt c'est assez impressionnant
en fonction de la trace ils vont ils
vont pouvoir nous dire bellego ils sont
passés par là ou au contraire qu'ils ont
pris un autre chemin
[Musique]
je crois qu'ils ont repéré quelques
d'oiseaux
tél
[Musique]
il facilité pour repérer les traces pour
observer la ville d'agde animal c'est
incroyable quoi qu'on peut se fit en
tout cas leur jugement ils voient les
choix de bien avant nous les systèmes
pour moi c'est ça mais klein professeur
des tentatives c'est le kit on appris
oui oui on y connaît en matière de la
nati la faune et la flore du parc
national de kahuzi biega oui c'est soit
des boussole naturelle
ils connaissent absolument tout de la
forêt fouesnant tout
[Musique]
ce que j'aime lorsqu'on rentre en forêt
c'est le silence
c'est toujours la même sensation le même
ravissement devant le spectacle de la
nature
[Musique]
l'intérêt c'est d'écouter et observer
lorsque j'étais jeune le fait de penser
à l'afrique et aux animaux me rendait
fou de bonheur le bonheur je peux pas
l'expliquer mais c'était comme s'il y
avait des particules de bonheur qui met
dans le mille ans d j'avais envie
d'aller au kenya je rêvais d'aller au
kenya par exemple pour aller voir les
grands animaux les rangs zerbib or dans
les plaines des grandes réserves et puis
finalement ça a été les gorille parce
que les gorilles ont toujours fasciné
m'ont toujours impressionné
un jour j'avais 20 ans c'était en 1984
je peux trouver dans un magasin et j'ai
vu une couverture de livre et c'était la
tête d'un gorille est un titre qui pour
moi était magique 13 ans chez les
gorilles et donc j'ai acheté ce livre et
à la lecture de ce bouquin formidable ma
passion a été décuplée je n'avais jamais
entendu parler de diane fossé avant
l'achat de son livre diane fossey et une
américaine une primatologue qui a
travaillé pendant 18 ans au contact des
gorilles de montagne elle a fait
beaucoup pour que ces gorilles soient
protégés et même sauvé et j'ai été
fasciné par son action j'ai vraiment été
en admiration devant cette femme qui a
tout donné pour la protection des
gorilles
[Musique]
le 27 décembre 1985 j'ai appris la mort
devient de fos et je peux retrouver chez
moi devant mon poste de télévision et le
journaliste je m'en souviens je suis
même de son nom a annoncé ce terrible
décès qui était un drame pour moi j'ai
ressenti cette annonce comme un
véritable choc et donc à partir de là je
n'ai réfléchis tu dis oui j'ai créé
gorilla et puis là ça a été le début
d'une belle aventure
[Musique]
cette marche en forêt me rappelle
forcément en première visite au gorille
c'était en 1986 au parc des volcans au
rwanda
la première fois que j'ai vu un gorille
je me suis dit mais quelle masse c'était
vraiment impressionnant je me suis
approché avec le guide et donc je me
suis allongé le plus près possible de
lui jusqu'à jusqu'à gagner centimètre
par centimètre et presque le toucher
ça a été donc une expérience unique
parce que ce gorille ne m'avait jamais
vu ne connaissait pas et puis tout d'un
coup il m'a acceptée sur son territoire
et près de lui
donc j'ai été vraiment aux anges
j'en garde un très très grand souvenir
j'étais venu pour les voir pour les
rencontrer cette rencontre a été à la
hauteur de ce que j'attendais à partir
de là je savais que j'allais m'engager
dans la durée
l'année dernière j'ai pas eu l'occasion
de revenir la cote du pot vide
c'est donc j'ai hâte de revoir
notre ami bonne année
c'est pas mal magnifique
tu as une vingtaine d'années qui a
réussi à fonder sa propre famille
sa banque ça descend ça glisse on tombe
souvent aussi on est forcément il peut
souffler
les pistes de gori ils sont caractérisés
par les déchets des fêtes image par
exemple il suffit de manger les écorces
et les faits isolés sélectif ici ça
c'est ouvert ça c'est au rire ou rire à
ccc liliane préféré parler gorille et
c'est là même il ya ici qu'ils utilisent
comme deux des antibiotiques quand ils
sont blessés et lui dit qu'est ce qui
fait du pôle été imaginé t il prend les
efforts avec les draps et des couleurs à
l'esstic jette le stic
c'est un guide des médias papa lambert
comme serait de passage ici c'est moi
qui aurait mangé ici et voilà la vérité
aux prises
et nous sommes déjà
en 2100 mètres d'altitude après tout si
on le sent qu'on est des gones altitude
oui tout cas c'est magnifique
à ton avis comment il va nous accueillir
le dos argenté très bien très bien les
coolies il est bien habitué il n'a pas
de problèmes concernant là vous allez
voir comment ces attitudes mais j'ai
tellement confiance à bonal il me
connaît et reconnaît ring et collèges et
vicat samarraï les pygmées delà de la
gestation jpy comme à la gestation
évolué comment il est né comment il a
grandi et si tu l'as vu naître deux
minutes
voilà maintenant l'unique du si beau ah
bah voilà rouleau là là c'est quand même
autre chose
le nez du nid du diplo orienté ça donne
la mesure un peu du problème quoi vous
vous voyez les pâtissiers les codes des
films et de ça va vous montrer que c'est
l'échec parce que même si je te dire
l'impression que j'ai eu un regard
nantes a tout de suite c'était que
j'étais dans jurassic park
c'était quelque chose les chais pas un
dinosaure c'est impressionnant dans les
autres pays peuvent condamner ces deux
cd ça c'est quoi déjà des 50 kg 200 250
kg et bon écoute je vais te suivre je
vais rester derrière toi
[Musique]
c'est choquant
pour l'heure mon dieu
il faut que tu sois attentif il faut pas
lâcher les appareils parce que citoyen
n'importe quel comportement il faut le
prendre
tu veux dire ll faut pas tergiverser
quoi
je
vous êtes
[Musique]
ça vaut combien elle est magnifique
j'adore les d'orienter qui sont les
grands mâles qui composent les familles
de gorilles pour moi c'est c'est
l'animal le plus formidable qui puisse
exister donc lorsque je suis au contact
du d'orienter mais je le regarde le fixe
je suis émerveillé émerveillé je peux
rester des heures à le contempler je me
dis mais quelle chance tu as de te
retrouver ici dans la forêt au milieu
des gorilles c'est une chance inouïe aux
côtés de nestlé bonne année ils sont des
deux là et qui s'appelle
oui longo la voile à regarder un petit
eux ce bébé magnifique ce jeune gorille
l'acquis tout à fait tranquille en
pleine d'entrain qui n'est pas un
sacrifice mais sans favori comme ça il
ya des points de vue qui tacle appuyé
les cas ils tapent la patrie c'est le
signe de joie nous montrer qui je suis
très content aussi de vous voir dans
made you top
contre le vent
ça c'est encore rien hanifi kapan je
flânais pas aussi bien
le gorille c'est le plus grand de tous
les sièges il peut peser jusqu'à 200 kg
mesure et 1 mètre 80 donc c'est un
animal qui présente une force colossale
qui est fascinant par sa force
ils font des vocalises qui ressemble par
exemple
ça rassure toute la famille et ça permet
aussi de donner des indications à tous
les membres de la famille pour pose bien
situés dans l'épaisse végétation les à
la fois le d'orienter tel ou tel
femelles c'est leur manière de
communiquer parfois comme le feuillage
est très épais on a l'impression qu'ils
sont loin les uns des autres mais
réalité qui sont toujours très très
proches
ce qui est étonnant c'est de voir tous
les enfants ensuite et les femelles qui
suivent son sillage pour ensuite
chercher chercher leur nourriture
donc c'est mal c'est noir jantes et qui
conduit la famille qui est respecté par
tous les membres la banane et qu'il
allait les tout autour de lui en cdd
qu'il s'en charger pour épouiller le
corps de deux des papas ça c'est l'amour
familial entre les individus mâles je
pense que le gorille arrive à comprendre
pourquoi nous allons le voir
pourquoi dans l'observer on est acceptée
jeu je crois absolument au fait que le
gorille
comprends l'homme comme une espèce
quasiment semblables il est difficile de
communiquer directement avec eux parce
que évidemment on parle pas le même
langage pour autant pour autant il ya
dans le regard quelque chose qui se
passe
personnellement je peux pas comprendre
qu'on puisse faire du mal un gorille et
n'importe quel animal moi j'ai grandi
dans le respect du vivant et à partir de
là je ne peux pas admettre qu'on puisse
faire du mal à un animal un gorille un
éléphant ou un autre animal
si on n'est pas capable de protéger les
gorilles à protéger les grands singes
les chimpanzés comment vous voulez quoi
qu'on puisse se protéger la forêt vous
protéger d'autres d'autres animaux ce
sont nos proches cousins
on a des ancêtres communs donc on ne
peut pas imaginer un monde sans gorilla
monde son gorille 50 sièges c'est tout
le monde qui a perdu son humanité
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que ce documentaire vous
a plu si le sujet de la protection des
grands singes vous intéresse sachez que
sur notre plateforme de streaming brut x
j'ai pu interviewer dans un décor
incroyable une des plus grandes
primatologue jane goudal avec qui j'ai
longtemps discuté de comment on peut
faire pour sauver les animaux orné du
comment avez vous réussi à convaincre le
monde entier que nous devions sauver les
grands singes vous savez il y a deux
façons de choquer les gens
l'une est de montrer le genre de vidéos
qui m'attend choqué quand j'ai vu des
chimpanzés dans des caches minuscule
mais l'autre est de leur montrer
simplement des photos de chimpanzés la
veine vivent leur vie en liberté dans la
forêt française abonnés si vous voulez
voir cette interview passionnante
moi je travaille sur des très gros
projets qui vont arriver bientôt sur la
plateforme
j'ai hâte de vous en parler a très vite